- Welcome back.
Our next guest is a guitarist and singer
who's well on her way to
true country star status,
and her journey getting there
has been filled with so
many cool twists and turns.
You can pick up her debut album now,
it's called "Welcome To The Block Party,"
which is an amazing title,
'cause her name is Priscilla Block!
(country music plays)
(audience applause)
I love you, I love you!
- Oh my God, I'm freaking out.
I'm obsessed with you.
- Oh my God, you're so nice.
- I'm literally so obsessed with you.
- You're like one of
the new artists I did,
I literally was listening and, true story,
and I was like, who is this?
And I started looking you up on Spotify.
I love your vibe.
- Thank you!
- I love your songs, I love your voice,
I love everything about you.
So you were almost giving
up and working hard,
as all artists do in the beginning,
and something made you not give up.
So tell everybody what that
was, 'cause it's amazing.
- Aw.
Yeah, so I'm like a year into Nashville.
and like Nashville is,
I'm this young girl, I'm 18 years old,
I have no clue what I'm
doing, where to start.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I'm about a year into town
and crumbling just day by day.
- Yeah.
- And I call my sister
one day and I was like,
"Hey, I have no clue
what I'm doing out here."
And you know, it was just the whole, like,
"if you come home, you didn't
fail, like, it's okay."
And that day Taylor Swift was driving by,
and I was leaving work,
and I was wearing this
Taylor swift t-shirt,
and she was just driving by
and saw me standing there
and was like, "Hey, I love your shirt."
- I love that she did this.
- I know, and I'm like,
"what is my life?" You know?
- And it really.
- But she had no idea
the impact that that would make,
'cause you were thinking of quitting,
and that had to have been like,
"this is a sign from God."
- Oh, it was crazy.
I'm like, I'm quitting my
job, I'm quitting school,
and I'm gonna go figure this out.
I don't know how to, how to do it,
but I'm gonna figure it out.
I'm like, that doesn't
even, that doesn't happen.
- No, but sometimes you-
no, that does not happen,
that's the craziest story ever,
and I, but I think it's so cool
and telling of her character,
that's very cool that
she did that for one,
and you have no idea the impact
you'll make on someone's life,
and like how it will change their lives.
Okay, so wait, so TikTok
played a huge role
in your new success, right?
So, explain how that happened.
- Gosh, you know, obviously
when the pandemic hit,
I'd been in Nashville
for almost eight years,
just grinding, working every single job
that I could to pay my bills.
- Yeah, and a lot of artists suffered,
- Yeah, I'm like, "what am I gonna do?"
- Yep.
- Like everything that
I've worked for is done.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'm four months behind on my rent,
I have to move outta my apartment.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- Full on.
- [Kelly] Nothing more like that
tend to force you to
get, like, innovative.
- Yes!
- But it's cool, so this happened.
- So TikTok was just like the app
that everyone was talking about.
I'm thinking it's this dancing app,
I'm learning the WAP in my kitchen,
and impersonating the Kardashians.
Like I had no clue that I was gonna use it
to help, basically launch my career.
And I started seeing, you know,
I would post cover videos,
and then I would post videos
of me singing my original songs
and the original songs just
started kind of blowing up.
And then I wrote a song
called "Just About Over You."
- Yeah, great song.
- And I released it within
like three weeks of writing it.
I knew that there was gonna
be some sort of moment,
I had no clue that my life
was just going to completely change.
(audience applause)
- I love that though.
You also did a song about body positivity,
which I love, and it's
called "Thick Thighs,"
you've gotta check it out.
So what inspired you to write it?
- I mean, I'm a curvy girl,
I will always be a curvy girl.
And I think that there was
just something so freeing
in writing that song, you know?
And if I can inspire
- [Kelly] It's relatable!
- anybody to love their self.
Oh my God, me twerking everywhere. Jesus!
- My favorite is with the hose, like.
- The hose, yeah.
- 'Cause here's the thing,
I love, I love your vibe,
I love your music, I love your voice,
I think it's like authentically country,
that's what I love most about it.
But your personality is awesome as well,
and people don't realize with artists,
like they wanna see your
personality as well.
And yours is amazing.
And that shows true
with that song as well.
And it's very relatable.
So you put out an album,
I love what it's called.
Very good play on your name.
So tell us about the album as a whole.
- "Welcome to the Block Party," baby.
I say it's like all the sass,
all the trash, and all the sad.
- [Kelly] All the in between.
- Me, as a whole.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's basically me and an album.
- I know, but those are all the songs
people wanna hear too, so.
- Yeah, I'm really excited about it.
I mean, this is my
first full length album.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you!
- Yeah.
- I am really, really excited,
I can't believe it's here.
- I love it, I'm so excited for you.
- [Priscilla] Thank you.
- I'm excited to see what you're gonna do
in country music too.
- [Priscilla] Thank you.
- I just think you're a really rad artist,
so thank you for taking
the time to come on here.
- I'm obsessed, anytime!
Call me whenever you want, I'm here.
- I also think you'd be fun to drink with.
- That too.